hablemos de la interferencia de la
ranura sencilla y yo en su lugar me
molestaría con esto de la interferencia
de una sola ranura como ocurre una
interferencia de onda en una sola ranura
una interferencia requiere por
definición de muchas ondas que se
sobrepongan en el mismo punto así que
cómo es posible que una misma ranura
produzca varias ondas que se sobrepongan
si tuviéramos una doble ranura si
pusiera una barrera aquí tendríamos dos
ranuras y ahora sí si yo envío una onda
aquí cuando llega a la ranura ya sabemos
que la onda se va a disfrazar o se va a
propagar con las ranuras sabemos que
tendremos dos ondas que se van a estar
propagando y ahora sí se van a trasladar
generando interferencia pero como vamos
a tener esto con una sola ranura
aún no les digo el porqué o una onda se
propaga en primer lugar al llegar a una
ranura cuál es la razón de que ocurra
una distracción la respuesta a esta
pregunta es la clave para comprender la
interferencia de la ranura sencilla el
hecho de que una onda se propague al
llegar a una ranura se le llama
principio dejo jens quien fue un físico
holandés cuyo apellido es fácil de
escribir pero no tan sencillo de
pronunciar quien descubrió esto y pido
disculpas a todos aquellos holandeses
que estén viendo este vídeo por mi mala
pronunciación de este apellido huygens
hizo algo muy ingenioso para explicar
esto tenemos estos frentes de onda que
recordamos son los picos de la onda y en
medio de ellos están los valles de la
onda si tenemos un frente de onda que se
dirige hacia acá él se dio cuenta de que
en el caso de las ondas podemos tratar
cada punto en esta onda como una fuente
de otra
que se propaga esféricamente con
dirección hacia adelante esto lo podemos
tener con cada uno de estos puntos oigan
dice que podemos tratar un frente de
onda con una serie infinita de fuentes
de onda cada punto es la fuente de otra
onda y ustedes podrían pensar que esto
es tremendamente complicado que relajó
nos va a dejar esto bueno pues si
acumulamos todas las interferencias
constructivas y destructivas de estas
fuentes infinitas nos dará otro frente
de onda como éste qué locura sin embargo
es cierto si tenemos que cada punto en
esta onda es a su vez la fuente u origen
de otra onda al acumularse sus
interferencias nos da como resultado
este otro frente de onda y esto es la
clave para comprender por qué se da la
difracción aquí la onda ya viene
disfrazándose por decirlo así cada uno
de los puntos de aquí se está
disfrazando pero al acumularse con la
dirección de otros
puntos nos da otro frente de onda pero
cuando se encuentra con una barrera o
algo que interrumpe el camino estas son
las ya no pueden sumarse a sus
compañeras solo este punto se propaga y
este otro punto también todos los demás
se bloquean y como están bloqueados ya
no pueden interferir constructivamente y
destructivamente con estas otras ondas
es por eso que lo que vemos que pasa por
las ranuras es otra onda completa cada
punto de cada frente de onda ya venía
disfrazándose sólo que no lo notábamos
porque la interferencia mutua de todos
los puntos es lo que forma cada frente
de onda y solo cuando tenemos una ranura
y una barrera como en este caso es que
nos damos cuenta de este hecho
esta es la clave para comprender la
interferencia de una ranura debido a que
si nos deshacemos de esto e imaginamos
que tenemos una onda por aquí y va a
llegar a esta parte y como cada punto en
la onda es a su vez una fuente de otra
onda cada uno de estos puntos se va a
propagar y cuando llegan a la ranura
tendremos una cantidad infinita de
fuentes de ondas y ya que algunas de
ellas estarán bloqueadas podremos ver
algunas de las interferencias
proyectadas en esta pared porque éstas
no pueden interactuar ni interferir con
las demás
o el patrón de interferencia vamos a ver
pues justo en el centro tendremos un
gran punto brillante y yo pensaría que
esto sería todo pues estamos haciendo
pasar la luz por un agujero y habrá un
punto brillante al centro pero aquí lo
más extraño es que tendremos otro punto
un poco brillante a un lado y luego otro
punto no tan brillante juntos
estos puntos de luz no van a ser muy
pronunciados tendremos un gran punto
brillante al centro y tendremos algunos
puntos no tan brillantes a los lados lo
mismo ocurre aquí abajo
este es el patrón de interferencia que
vamos a ver y ahora nos toca entender
cómo es que esto se forma aquí dijimos
que tenemos una cantidad infinita de
fuentes de onda las cuales me tardaría
mucho en dibujar por lo que sólo voy a
dibujar ocho aquí dibujo mis ocho
fuentes y aquí lo extraño es la
disminución de la luz aquí esta
interferencia destructiva la onda que
viene de este punto hasta arriba tuvo
que viajar esta distancia para llegar a
este punto en la pantalla y también
vamos a analizar el quinto punto hacia
abajo el cual está casi a la mitad del
camino
lo que quiero probar aquí es que si
estas dos fuentes
en este punto tienen interferencia
destructiva entonces todas las fuentes
lo tendrán también
ya hemos jugado este juego vamos a
dibujar nuestro ángulo recto y si estas
ondas tienen interferencia destructiva
esto qué es lo que sobra de esta
longitud de ruta tiene que medir para
que sea destructiva media longitud de
onda o tres medios de longitud de onda o
cinco medios de longitud de onda
etcétera debe tener esta proporción para
ser destructiva si ese es el primer
punto entonces esto será media longitud
de onda y cuál es la relación de este
ángulo de este punto en la pared con
respecto a la línea central eso ya lo
encontramos
recuerden que esa proporción está dada
por de porción o de teta igual a la
diferencia en la ruta entre estas dos
rutas
recordamos que la pantalla tenía que
estar muy alejada en comparación con el
ancho del agujero pero esta relación
sigue aplicándose cuál será d en este
caso ahora debemos ser mucho más
cuidadosos ya que esta ranura tiene
cierto ancho que le llamamos w
si esta ranura tiene un ancho w que tan
separados deben estar estos no tienen
una separación de w sino de wwf en una
separación de w entre 2 y tengo que ver
por seno de teta es igual a la
diferencia en la longitud de la ruta
ahora b va a ser w entre 2 x el seno del
ángulo que ambas rutas forman al llegar
a la pantalla y la diferencia en la
longitud de las rutas tiene que ser
lambda entre 2 para que sea destructiva
esto ya se ve un poco extraño porque
vean puedo cancelar estos dos y que me
queda pues nos queda w
que es el ancho total de esta ranura
multiplicado por el seno de theta que es
igual a lambda
esto me da interferencia destructiva
recuerden que antes todos los puntos que
coincidían o eran múltiplos de la
longitud de onda
eran constructivos
pero en este caso nos da interferencia
destructiva esto vino del juego de usar
doble o entre 2 como de en la ecuación y
luego cancelamos estos dos pero aún no
demuestro que todas las demás fuentes
también son destructivas en este punto
de pantalla solo lo demostré para estas
dos fuentes y recuerden que aquí hay una
cantidad infinita de fuentes así que
como vamos a demostrar esto bueno pues
vamos a emparejar los ahora imaginen que
nos pasamos al punto de abajo ahora
considero que esta es la onda que viaja
hasta acá y también vamos a elegir la
fuente que está abajo de la que teníamos
abajo y ahora imagino que ambas viajan
hacia este punto cierta distancia que es
relación tendrán estas 2 pues están
separadas una distancia de doble uve
entre dos esto de aquí también es doble
o entre dos por lo que tendremos la
misma relación w entre dos por el seno
de teta
será el mismo ángulo si es el mismo
ángulo que tendremos en la pantalla ya
que lleguen al mismo punto y la pantalla
está tan alejada que estas líneas llegan
casi paralelas esto va a ser igual a lo
que teníamos arriba wv entre dos por el
seno del mismo ángulo nos dará lambda
entre dos todo lo de aquí abajo es igual
a lo que está aquí arriba por lo que
también será destructivo
estas dos fuentes en este punto también
serán destructivas y puedo seguir
haciendo esto para todos los pares de
puntos de estas fuentes
y todos estos tendrán una interferencia
destructiva puedo aniquilar cada onda al
emparejar la con un compañero que sea
destructivo para esta y ahora si puedo
decir que este es un punto destructivo
en este punto se destruye toda la luz
en resumen esta relación de wv que es el
ancho de la ranura multiplicado por el
seno de teta que es el mismo ángulo que
hemos venido usando va a ser igual a m
por lambda múltiplos de la longitud de
onda en esta ocasión y aquí hay que
tener mucho cuidado esto nos dará los
puntos destructivos y no los puntos
constructivos como lo vimos en la
ocasión anterior esto nos dará los
puntos destructivos y quizás ustedes me
digan oye solo vimos que esto se cumple
para cuando m es igual a 1 bueno de
forma muy sencilla podemos probar que
esto se cumple para 3 lambda entre 2 o
para 5 lambda entre 2 todos éstos nos
darán los enteros impares aquí m no
puede ser 0 y de esto hablaremos en un
momento puede ser 1
2 3 4 5 etcétera ya hicimos la
demostración para uno ya vimos que para
tres también tendremos interferencia
destructiva para m igual a 5 también
tendremos estos dos que se cancelan así
que se cumple para el 5 qué pasa con los
valores pares los padres significan que
no tuve que emparejar el de arriba con
el de enmedio que es de donde viene el w
entre 2 y si hago esto puedo dividirlo
entre cualquier entero puedo imaginar
emparejar este punto en lugar de elegir
el de arriba y el de enmedio puedo
elegir el de arriba y emparejarlo con el
punto que está después el que está junto
la distancia entre ambas fuentes va a
ser doble o entre 4
y si estos dos se cancelan entonces los
dos que siguen abajo este de aquí y sdk
también se cancelarían siguiendo el
mismo razonamiento puedo hacer lo mismo
para todos los padres de puntos
siguientes pero ahora la división de w
sería entre 4 no le puedo dividir entre
3 o entre 2.5 porque siempre quiero
formar parejas de 2 ese es el plan y es
mi estrategia aquí cancelar las fuentes
en parejas y puedo hacer esto al dividir
el ancho entre cualquier número par que
nos dará w entre 4 pues doble o entre 4
por el seno de teta igual a lambda entre
si simplificó esto me quedara wv por el
seno de teta igualados por lambda por lo
que m igualados también nos funciona
para la interferencia destructiva puedo
dividirlo entre 8 y nos dará 4 puedo
dividir entre cualquier número par y
cualquier entero aquí me dará
interferencia en este punto de la
pantalla este será m igual a 1
este será m igualados y así continuamos
hacia arriba por lo que esta relación
nos da los puntos destructivos porque no
podemos tener m
0 no es un punto destructivo porque m
igual a 0 se encuentra justo en el medio
y es el punto más constructivo este de
enmedio por lo que m no es un punto
destructivo pero cualquier otro entero
no será un punto destructivo
esta es la fórmula para encontrar todos
los puntos destructivos
wv es el ancho total de la ranura única
teta es el ángulo que medimos al
imaginar la línea central y otra línea
que llega a nuestro punto en la pantalla
ese es el ángulo theta y m es cualquiera
entero diferente de 0 lambda es la
longitud de la onda de la luz que
estamos enviando aquí
esto nos da los puntos destructivos y me
pueden decir oye soy bastante listo si
los enteros nos dan puntos destructivos
entonces las mitades de estos enteros no
serán los puntos constructivos
si tengo w por el seno de theta igual a
lambda entre 2 o 3 lambda entre 2 no
serán los puntos constructivos
la respuesta es que no aquí tenemos
algunas complicaciones y si están
interesados en saber el porqué de esto
haré otro vídeo para explicar por qué si
han prestado atención encontrarán otra
cosa que puede molestarles y es algo que
mencioné antes y que podría hacernos
creer que esto no ocurre con el
gradiente de difracción nosotros
demostramos entre comillas que éstas no
ocurren y si les molesta algo de esto o
si quieren saber por qué la fórmula
constructiva no nos da exactamente los
puntos constructivos vean ese vídeo y si
están contentos con lo que ya sabemos
esto nos dará los puntos destructivos en
la pantalla